翻訳: Kyoko Kamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
こんにちは
早速なんですけれども
皆さん 英語好きな方
どれくらいいらっしゃいますか？
さすがですね
僕はですね 英語が実は非常に嫌いでした
嫌いだけど できるやつとか
たまにいるじゃないですか
僕はほんとに英語ができなくて
高校３年生の時の英語の偏差値が39で
100点満点の穴埋め式の
テストがあってですね 英語の —
一応全部がんばって埋めきったんですけど
埋めきって返ってきた答案が４点だった時に
（笑）
もう英語一生使わないで生きていこうって
いうふうに ほんとにそう思ってました
大学はたまたま定期試験の推薦で
行くことができたんですけど
ほんとにそういう意味で言うと
僕自身は非常に世界とか
グローバルっていうキーワードと
遠いところにいた人間だったなと
いうふうに思っています
そんな僕がですね なんでいきなり
世界っていうものを意識し始めたのか
それはですね 大学[で]上京して
大学２年の時に友人と一緒に会社を
起業してですね ビジネスをやっていました
そのビジネスをやって1年くらいで
ある程度ですね
軌道に乗ってきたなぁって時だったんですね
その時にたまたま
外資系の戦略コンサルで働いてるですね —
すごい大先輩の方がいて
その方と出会ったのが
僕の大きなきっかけになりました
その方がですね 勉強会で４時間くらい
いろんな問答をされてですね
すごい あーだこーだ言われて
僕らの自信が木っ端微塵になっていくという
すごい勉強会だったんですけども
その中でひとつ印象的だった話があります
その方が僕らに投げかけました
「グローバルにビジネスを展開するっていうのは
どういうふうな展開の仕方を
すればいいのかわかりますか？」
その時ですね 僕は元気よく手を挙げて
「はい」と —
まずいいアイデアがあったら
それを東京でやって
うまくいったらそれを大阪とか関西でやって
名古屋でやって
東名阪でうまくいけば
それを北海道や九州でやって
日本でうまくいったら
それを韓国、中国、アジア —
ヨーロッパ、アメリカ
そういうふうに世界に広げていく
それがグローバルにビジネスを
展開していくことなんじゃないでしょうかと
非常に自信を持ってですね
答えたつもりだったんですけれども
その方にはですね
「全然ダメだね」と
「グローバルのグの字もわかってないね」
と言われたんですね
正直ですね その時はですね
「何言ってんだこのやろう」と
思った部分が[ありました]
「これがグローバルじゃなくて
何がグローバルなんだ」
もしかしたらみなさんの中にも僕と同じように
今思った方もいるかもしれないです
その方がじゃあ何が言いたかったかと言うと
本当にグローバルにやる人っていうのは
例えば何かいいアイデアがあったら
それは日本で必要とされないかもしれないけど
メキシコだったら必要とする人が
いるんじゃないかとか
例えばメキシコで流行っているサービスを
エジプトに持っていっても
流行るんじゃないかとか
それは別に対「国境」の話だけではなくて
例えば じゃあ豚肉を使わない料理を
新しく作りました
このレストラン イスラムの人たちに
食べてもらえるんじゃないかと
イスラムの人って世界のどこにいますか
別に対「国」とか「国境」ではなくて
中東の方にももちろんいますし
インドネシアとかマレーシアとか
アジアにもいますし
アメリカとか日本っていうですね
少なからずそういうところにも
イスラムの人たち[は]いるわけです
そう考えるとグローバルっていうのは
ほんとに言葉の通り globeって
地球から来てるんですけど
ほんとにこの世界で
どこで誰が何を必要としているのか
それをちゃんと考えることができて
実際にそれをアクションに
落とし込んでいける人だと
その方が「じゃあそういうのやれてるのは
どんな人なの？」って言った時に
例えばユダヤ人や華僑の人がそうだろうと
彼らは世界中に繋がりがあるから
実際に日本に来て「あ なんか
おもしろいもの売ってるな これ —
なんか これメキシコでも
流行るんじゃないか」って
メキシコ人の友達に電話一本連絡して
「それおもしろそうだな」と
「じゃあメキシコでやってみようよ」みたいな
そういうようなスピード感を持って
世界を舞台に彼らは活動していると
そんな話をされたのが
僕が大学４年生の時でした
正直ですね「脳天に雷が落ちる」って
このことだなと思ってですね
僕はほんとに自信満々に
「グローバルとはこうだ」と言ったのが
全否定されてですね
その後にそういう話をいただいて
「あ 全然そういう発想を
したことがなかった」と
いつも何か考えたら東京でやることとか
日本で広めることしか考えてなかったんですね
僕は世のため人のためになるような
サービスとかアイデアを
どんどん作っていきたいっていうふうに
思っていたんですけれども
それも気づいたら勝手に自分の中で
日本の中 日本人のためだけにっていう
リミットがかかってしまっていたんだなと
いうふうに その時気づかされました
そんな自分のですね リミットを外したい
そう思ってですね
僕はずーっと逃げてきた英語を
なんとかしなきゃいけない
あとは世界中にそういう仕事の相談も
できるような友達を作りたい
そして実際に今世界がどうなっているのか
世界でどういうことが
必要とされているのかを知りたい
この３つをクリアするために
僕はその当時起業した会社を辞めて
世界に出ることにしました
それで僕はですね
まず英語が全くできなかったので
最初フィリピンに行って
英語の勉強をしていました
まぁ英語留学をしていたんですけれども
その留学の最後の１か月の時に
非常に印象的な出会いがありました
フィリピン人のですね —
まだ当時22歳くらいの若者３人組
彼らはですね 外資系の広告代理店で
働いていたんですけども
彼らはまだ就職して１年目
１年目がようやく終わる頃だったんです
僕は話をしていたら 彼らはですね —
カフェだったんですけど
「じゃあ次どこで働こうか」って
そういう話題になったんですね
もう転職するのかと 早いなと
どこ行くんだろうと
じゃあ業界トップの大手に行くのかな
とかですね ベンチャーに行くのかなとか
もしくは独立するのかなとか
それとも全然違う職業職種に行くのかなとか
そんなことをですね 僕は想像していました
ところが彼らの会話から出てきたのは
全く別の言葉でした
「えー 俺次どこで働こうかな」
「俺はロンドンがいいな」
「え 俺はシンガポールか香港がいいな」
「俺はアメリカ
でも東京もおもしろそうだよね」
そういう会話が彼らから
当たり前のように出てきたんですね
僕はとてつもない衝撃を受けました
二十何年生きてきて 日本の友達の中で
就職活動や転職活動で
そういうスケールから会話が始まったことは
一度もありませんでした
みんな「いやー就職だったらどこ行きたい？」
「商社行きたい」とか
「メガバンク行きたい」とかですね
「電通行きたい」とかそういう会話は出ても
「えー 俺はロンドンにするか
アメリカにするか迷ってるよ」とか
そういう会話って みなさんどうですか？
あまり聞き慣れなかった人[が]
多いんじゃないかなと思います
ただ僕は彼らが当たり前のように
その会話をしていることに
本当にその当時 衝撃を受けました
そんな彼らとの出会いをですね 後にして
僕は改めて海外に出る思いを強くするんですが
その後ですね フィリピンを離れて
２年間50か国 ずーっと旅をしていました
フィリピンの後にはまず北米に行って
中米に行って 南米に行って
北アフリカ、東アフリカ
ヨーロッパ、中東
南アジア、東アジア、東南アジア
っていう形で旅をしていました
僕はバックパッカーだったんですけども
バックパックの中にはスーツ一式、革靴
一応ですね オフィシャルな場所にも
出れるようにしていて
どうしても訪問したい会社があれば —
アメリカに行けばグーグルとかアップルの
オフィスに行ってみたりとか
イスラエルで起業家の —
スタートアップの起業家がプレゼンするような
ピッチに参加させてもらったりとか
そういう場所に行かせてもらったり
その一方で
例えばアフリカのスラム街に
潜り込ませてもらったりとかですね
ほんとにとにかくいろんな場所をですね
自分の２年間という時間を使ってですね
できる限りのことを学びたいと思って
いろんな場所に飛び込ませていただきました
その中で僕の旅には
幾つかのテーマがあったんですけれども
ひとつ それはやっぱりインターネット
WEBを駆使して旅をしていました
例えばですね カウチサーフィン
みなさんが知ってそうなのだとAirbnb
あとはLinkedInとかMeetupとか
いろんなインターネットのサービスが
今 普及しています
世界中でいろんな人が使っています
そういったサービスを使って
世界中の人の家に泊まり歩いていました
出会いまくってました
バックパッカーなのに
１日５アポありました
もうちょっと笑ってもらいたかったです
（笑）
「俺なにやってるんだろう」みたいな
「今日５アポで追われている」みたいな
そういうのがあったんですけど
でも非常に楽しい時間を —
やっぱりなぜそうしたかって言うと
やっぱりただその街を訪れるだけでは
目に入る情報しか入ってこないんですよね
それってすごく表面的な情報でしかなくて
その国が今どう動いているかとか
その国の人たちが何を考えているかとか
あと福祉ですとか教育ですとか
経済とか政治
そういった仕組みの話って
やっぱりわからないんですよね
それはやはり現地の人に出会って初めて
僕らはその情報を手に入れることができる
その情報を知らなかったら
僕らは只々昔の町並みを見に
旅をしているわけではなくて
今その土地がどうなっているのか知りたくて
旅をしていたので
現地の人に出会わないと
僕の旅は成立しなかったんですね
僕はそんなふうにしてだいたい150泊くらい
世界中の人の家に泊めてもらいながら
一千人ぐらいの人たちに出会いながら
ずーっと旅をしていきました
なので 泊めてもらった人の家の
冷蔵庫を開けてみたりとかすると
ドイツ人だったらやっぱりチーズばっかり
入ってるなとかですね
あとたまに開けて
ダイエット食品とか入ってた時に —
「申し訳ない」[と]閉めるとかですね
そういうことも経験としては
してきました
僕はですね 旅をしながら
もう一つやっていたのが
海外で戦っている日本人の人たち —
日本のビジネスマンに出会いながら
彼らの活動をレポートしながら
旅をしてたんですね
それは
「サムライバックパッカープロジェクト」って
プロジェクトを名付けて
旅をしていたんですけれども
その中でフィリピンで出会った時の出会いを
彷彿させるような出会いが
ひとつありました
それはロンドンで出会った
ワタナベさんという方だったんですけれど
彼は日本のコンサルの会社をですね
途中で辞めて
その後ロンドンで
ファイナンスの勉強をするって言って
ロンドンに来てたんですけども
彼にですね 僕は —
うがった見方じゃないんですけども
「ワタナベさん
なんでファイナンスの勉強をするのに
ロンドンに来たんですか？」と
「別にロンドンじゃなくてもできますよね
東京でよくないですか？
なんでワタナベさん
わざわざロンドンまで来たんですか？」
ワタナベさんは答えました
「いや 東京でも金融を勉強できると
思ったんですけど
でもどうせ勉強するならやっぱり
世界一の場所で勉強したいと思ったんです
それがたまたま東京じゃなくて
ロンドンだったと
ただそれだけですよ」と
彼はですね しれっと
答えてくれたんですけれども
あ これが頭に世界を描いている人の
発想なんだなという風に思いました
僕はですね
これまで何か可能性を求めた時 —
やっぱりみんな「東京に行こう」とか
「大阪に行こう」とか「神戸に行こう」とか
そういう思いでこの中にも
地方出身の方[が]たくさんいると思います
僕も出身は宮城です
でもやっぱりその都市部に集まる
なんでかって言うとやっぱり可能性を求めて
みんな集まってきたと思うんですね
ただですね それがこれまでは
可能性を求めた場所に行くのが
東京だったり大阪だったと思うんですけど
それが変わってきました
それが中国だったりシンガポールだったり
ロンドンだったり
いろんな場所に変わっていくわけです
例えば農業を勉強したいと思った時に
もちろん九州で勉強してもいいですし
北海道でやってもいい
でもアメリカで大規模農園の経営を勉強したり
キューバで有機農法を学ぶとか
いろんな選択肢があるわけですよね
で そもそもそういうアイデア ─ 発想を
持ってないとできるわけがないですよね
実際にできるかどうかは
物理的な要因とか 言語的な要因とか
経済的な要因で
できるできないは分かれますけど
アイデアをまず持っていないと
それはできない
そのアイデアを今日皆さんには
持ってもらいたいなと思って
今日ここに立っています
僕らはですね 気づいたら —
時代が変わっていた
そう言ったら なんかちょっと
浅はかな発言になってしまうんですけども
思いを返せば 江戸時代の延長線上に
いると思ってもらえれば
いきなり江戸の話[が]出てきた
と思うんですけども
江戸時代って関所[を通ら]ないと
江戸に行けなかったんですよね
通行手形がないと そこには関所があって
江戸に行けなかった時代があったわけです
それが しかも通行手形を手に入れたとしても
じゃあ何日かかって
どうやって江戸に行くんだろう？
そもそも江戸ってどういう場所なんだろう？
情報もない わからない
お父さんお母さん 次いつ会えるの？みたいな
今生の別れかもしれない
そういう時代が
150年ちょっと前にありました
でもそれから大きく時代が変わってきて
今どうですか？
僕 今朝 朝東京から
新幹線でやってきたんですけど
３〜４時間でここにも来れました
移動手段が発達をして
そもそも日本国内には
そういった関所なんて撤廃されていますし
好きな場所に行けるようにも
変わってきました
それだけではなくて
僕ら日本人のパスポートがあれば
世界のどこにでも行けるように
変わってきていますし 旅行だけではなくて
そこに実際住んで働くっていうことも
できるように変わってきました
大きく時代は変わってきました
そして何よりも
情報をインターネットで集める
検索して取得することができるように
変わってきました
そういう風に 時代の流れが
大きく変化をしてきています
なので 僕は今日皆さんに
一番お伝えしたいメッセージっていうのは
「頭の中にある日本地図を
世界地図に塗り変える」ということです
皆さんが何か勉強したいこととか
皆さんが何か極めたい仕事があった時に
それを今いる場所とか
日本の中だけではなくて
世界のどこで それを学んだり
それを極めていくのが
一番楽しいんだろう？とか
魅力に思えるんだろう？とか
そういう風に頭の中に
世界地図を描いて欲しいですね
今皆さんがやっている仕事
学んでいること
それが世界のどこでやったら
一番最先端でいけるんだろう
それを描いてほしいと思っています
皆さんが頭の中に世界地図をですね
今 かりそめの世界地図[を]
描いてもらってると思うんですけども
今皆さん あーだこーだと
考えていると思います
でも多分その世界地図は
まだすごく真っ白だと思うんですね
なんの味気もなくて
開いてみたもののよくわからない
じゃあその世界地図に
どうやって彩りを与えていくのか
それはやっぱり日々そこにアンテナを張って
日々のニュースを見たりとかですね
いろんな人に話を聞いたりする
もちろんそれでも彩りを
与えていくことはできます
ただ本物の彩りはやっぱり皆さんが
自分でその土地に訪れること
その土地に訪れてその土地に住んでいる人
学んでいる人 働いている人たちに
出会って話を聞いて 初めて
本当のイメージができます
あぁ自分はここに住んでみたいなとか
自分もここで仕事してみたいなとか
自分がここで学んでみたいなとか
そういった発想ができるような
本物の世界地図は
やっぱり皆さんが足を使って 肌で感じて
初めて手に入れることができると思います
僕らはですね この21世紀
あんまり周りに 皆さん —
世界に飛び立ってる先輩とか友達って
まだまだ少ないかもしれません
だからそんなに情報もありません
でも それはなんでかって言ったら
ようやくそういう時代に
シフトしてきたからなんです
ロールモデルがいないのは
やっとそういうことができる時代に
変わってきたからなんです
なので 今日会場に来てくださっている
皆さん一人ひとりが —
21世紀の世界を舞台に自由に生きていく
ロールモデルになって欲しいと思っていますし
僕自身もロールモデルになれたらと
思っています
そうしてその21世紀を 世界を舞台に
楽しく人生を歩んで行けたらと
そしたら非常に楽しく
過ごしていけるんじゃないかなと思います
以上
ありがとうございました
（拍手）